[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
futsal pour la deuxième fois la ville de
mantes la jolie a accueilli ce samedi 23
octobre un tournoi de futsal adapté pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
mental reportage dans ce magazine
football c'était une première depuis
1995 le fo plaisir organisé ce week-end
un tournoi international pour les moins
de 12 ans sur ces terrains au total 24
équipes dont huit clubs professionnels
ont fait le déplacement zoom dans ce set
8 sport golf coup de projecteur
aujourd'hui sur le golf de saint germain
en laye la structure est l'une des plus
anciennes de france elle fêtera l'année
prochaine ses 100 ans l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tv à 78
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va commencer par du tennis est une très
bonne nouvelle pour le tennis illinois
arthur rinderknecht saint germanois
vient d'être sélectionné pour participer
à la coupe davis qui se déroulera du 25
novembre au 5 décembre en autriche puis
en espagne sébastien grosjean le
capitaine a décidé de lui faire
confiance
arthur rinderknecht est l'une des plus
belles progressions du tennis français
ces derniers mois il pointe actuellement
à la 65e place mondiale on passe
maintenant résultats sportifs du
week-end dans les yvelines notre
journaliste bixente mais rien senti
steban nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonsoir bixente on sent michael alors ce
dimanche c'était la fin des championnats
du monde de cyclisme sur piste à roubaix
bixente quel est le bilan pour le
tricolore qui s'entraîne au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines un
bilan mitigé michael 1 sur les 22 09 qui
avaient lieu les français ont rapporté
six médailles c'est cinq de moins que
les allemands notamment grand vainqueur
de ces quatre jours de compétition c'est
aussi moins que les néerlandais les
italiens et les britanniques on
retiendra des deux médailles d'or
apportée par benjamin thomas à la course
aux points et donavan seconde en scratch
page en main thomas également en argent
au terme de la poursuite par équipe aux
côtés de thomas boudât thomas denys et
valentin tabellion notamment alors une
autre cycliste a rapporté deux médailles
il s'agit de sébastien ogier mais
exactement michael l'argent d'abord avec
flore un gringo est rien et la halle en
vitesse par équipes et le bronze tout
seul comme un grand cette fois en
vitesse individuelle côté féminin un
seul podium c'est clara copponi et marie
le net qui ont monté la deuxième marche
de l'américaine un bilan plutôt décevant
au total 1 on est armé mais on aurait
aimé voir marion bord est notamment ou
encore mathilde gros sur sur un podium
pendant ces quatre jours bon ce sera
pour une prochaine édition peut-être en
passe au reste des résultats du week-end
et on commence par du football oui avec
la 10e journée de national de versailles
toujours aussi solide une victoire 1 0 à
la maison contre rouen les versailles et
son deuxième à trois points de l'équipe
b de lorient autre club yvelinois de la
division poissy qui obtient le point du
nul contre guingamp b lépi sac et sont
11e avec 12 points de la régionale 3
présents et des yvelinois au top dans
cette division presque au top en tout
cas mickaël puisque les deux clubs du
département se trouve sur le podium
maurepas d'abord en tant que dauphin
après son match nul 1 partout contre
gretz tournan quant à versailles mais
une victoire par la plus petite des
marges 1-0 sur le terrain de charenton
qui les place à la troisième place le
chemin est encore long pour la montée
c'est la quatrième journée seulement
dans la division du rugby et plaisir qui
se relance j'ai envie de dire enfin vous
savez bien michael que plaisir connaît
un début de saison compliqué hein
peut-être que la victoire de ce week end
va être le déclic pour lancer
véritablement leur saison un succès 39
12 contre domont qui replace les
plaisirs aux à la huitième marche du
classement avec deux victoires et quatre
défaites prochain match pour enchaîner
après une semaine de repos le 7 novembre
contre la baule dans la division d'en
dessous on fédérale 3 où ils se baladent
les au vélo à la manière des all black
l'emportent 71 à 11 sur la pelouse de
dieppe une première victoire en quatre
matches pour mouiller avec le précieux
bonus offensif pas de bonus offensif
pour versailles en revanche fait une
victoire aussi 29 25 contre evreux
versailles son douzième deuxième avec 13
points en seulement trois matches
disputés on termine par du handball et
une défaite pour les féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux en national dont
effet 27 à 25 une déception pour les
inhumant ten qui n'avance pas elle qui
affichait de grandes ambitions dans
cette division elle stagne au milieu de
tableau une défaite qui ne rassure pas
avant une semaine de repos et la
réception du cercle rennes le 6 novembre
les co leaders du championnat mais qui
s'est justement c'est peut-être aussi
l'occasion de de créer la surprise en
tout cas on vous tiendra au courant
merci à bixente pour toutes ces
précisions va maintenant prendre la
direction de mantes la jolie pour la
deuxième fois la ville a accueilli ce
samedi à 23 octobre un tournoi de futsal
adapté pour les personnes en situation
de handicap mental des images de justin
ghazi
il on joue au football malgré leur
handicap mental ce samedi 23 octobre
cette équipe des illuminés de leur ont
participé à un tournoi de futsal
organisé au gymnase lui quand de
mantes-la-jolie 100 présente beaucoup de
progrès de leur présence pendant un an
légalement j'ai bien aimé ça m'a fait me
dépenser et
on appréciait de tournois ou quoi sous
verre au total ce deuxième rendez-vous a
permis à plus de 60 joueurs de pratiquer
leur passion ils étaient trois fois plus
nombreux que lors de la précédente
édition les matchs se sont déroulés de
13h30 à 17h chaque partie duré dix
minutes objectif prendre du plaisir il
n'y a pas grand chose qui change on va
être beaucoup plus souple en termes
d'arbitrages et
par rapport à chaque individualité
en gros
on peut on peut siffler certaines choses
à d'autres personnes qu'on connaît où on
va être un peu plus exigeant une
personne qui a une déficience un peu
plus profonde ou marquer on va être
beaucoup plus souple sur les règles on
pourra laisser un peu plus jouer donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas 100% les règles
du futsal mais on garde quand même cette
souplesse parce qu'on n'est pas c'est
pas le championnat du monde la
compétition a finalement été remporté
par l'équipe de mantes-la-jolie les
organisateurs ont déjà donné rendez vous
pour l'année prochaine la troisième
édition de ce tournoi de futsal de sport
adapté devrait de nouveau être programmé
en octobre
encore du football c'était une première
depuis 1995 le fo plaisir organisé ce
week end un tournoi international pour
les moins de 12 ans sur ces terrains au
total 24 équipes dont huit clubs
professionnels ont fait le déplacement
un montage de rémi lefebvre l'om le psg
ou encore le red star 24 équipes se sont
donné rendez vous sur les terrains du
stade bernard giroux de plaisir à
l'occasion de la challenge cup plaisir
un tournoi international pour les moins
de 12 ans organisé sur deux jours les 23
et 24 octobre où les amateurs ont côtoyé
les professionnels très très bien c'est
vraiment très très basse une expérience
pour eux plus tard à venir comment ça
joue commencé là-bas comment eux comment
ça se passe sur le terrain et aussi les
coachs c'est c'est eh bien puisque
il y à des équipes internationales qu'on
ne pourrait pas à affronter avant
longtemps comme le fc bruges
toulouse des équipes aussi comme neige
et marseille donc c'est cool de faire
venir des équipes comme ça à plaisir
c'est la première édition de ce tournoi
est un retour aux sources pour le club
de plaisir la structure avait organisé
un autre tournoi international minimes
entre 1981 et 1995 donc c'est vrai que
ça date et atebank la sape le tournoi
tall sall minimes et je rends hommage
effectivement mes prédécesseurs ceux qui
sont passés avant moi justement qui
avait mis en place au tournoi et soit là
c'est un petit un petit message aussi
que je le revois parce que moi j'ai du
souvenir de ce tournant là et ça me
tenait aussi à coeur en lien avec sa de
remettre ce type d'événement est de voir
tout ce monde là aujourd'hui ça fait ça
fait vraiment plaisir après deux jours
de tournoi c'est le club de bruges qui
remporte la compétition en battant le
football-club 93 en finale les
organisateurs plaisir on espère
désormais organiser un nouveau tournoi
l'année prochaine
chaque mois dans le 7-8 sport nous
faisons un point sur les jo de 2024 avec
notre journaliste grégory canal et
bonsoir gago et michael alors des city
vinoy pour le plus grand événement de
sport au monde ça on le sait mais aussi
de nouvelles disciplines qui font leur
entrée le breakdance par exemple sera
olympique en 2024 pourquoi ce choix et
bien tony estanguet président du comité
d'organisation de paris 2024 a été clair
les jeux seront urbain culturel et
éco-responsable il faut dire que le
breakdance coach toutes les cases la
discipline est née dans les années 70
dans les rues de new york une
effervescence trouver dans les fêtes du
quartier du bronx l'art qui mêle dans
ses figures acrobatiques s'est ensuite
exportée avec des premiers battle
internationaux et dans les années 90 et
pour le pratiquer pas besoin d'immenses
structures nickel le bitume suffit
ajoutez à cela un énorme succès aux jeux
de la jeunesse en 2018 en argentine le
break dance sera donc un sport
additionnel de paris 2024 aux côtés du
surf aux côtés également du skateboard
et de l' escalade et dans le milieu on
peut dire qu'on est ravi franchement je
suis trop content un peu comme tous les
autre bboy et bigot parce que ben
c'est un club simplement c'est
incroyable que le brix audio et bien
j'espère pouvoir y participer c'est une
grosse opportunité pour ceux qui pour
ceux qui dansent et on pourra avoir des
soutiens de l'aide a suivi médical une
bourse et ses terrasses et c'est
vraiment un grand pas dans le break et
surtout on va permettre de faire
connaître cette danse aux gens qui ne
connaissent pas encore ce qui change
c'est plus notre statut on va être
considérés comme des athlètes
et
vraiment dans leur dans le sens
légalement parce que pour moi je me
considérait déjà comme un athlète je vis
de mon corps et
c'est une discipline qui est quand même
c'est une danse est un art mais c'est
physique c'est très athlétique donc
voilà c'est c'est plus officiellement
légalement les considérer comme des
sportifs de haut niveau le breakdance
espère effectivement profité de
l'exposition olympique pour entrer dans
une nouvelle dimension fini la
débrouille la discipline veut se
structurer et se professionnalise à qui
à quoi va ressembler cette épreuve
olympique de breakdance et bien déjà le
lieu ce sera dans un stade ouvert
temporaire en plein coeur de paris une
transformation de la place de la
concorde pour accueillir le break mais
aussi le bmx freestyle le skateboard et
le basketball 3 contre 3 après le format
ce sera tout simplement des battles
d'ailleurs est ce qu'on dit un ou une
battle michael à votre avis une battle
et non on dit un battle et on insiste la
charge sur deux dans le milieu une
chance sur deux un battle et il y aura
deux épreuves une femme une homme pour
siéger au cese bgirls et 16 b-boys
qualifier c'est le nom qu'on donne à ces
athlètes ils s'affronteront dans des
battles en 1 contre 1 et devront
enchaîner les figures en s'adaptant et
en improvisant sur le son du dj hell les
athlètes seront départagés par un jury
pour remporter le premier titre
olympique de breakdance de l'histoire et
d'ici 2024 donc reste la sélection des
sportifs l'ultimate bat seul masters
dont la troisième édition se tenait il
ya quelques semaines à poissy souhaite
devenir un tournoi préparatoire de
l'événement on se positionne un peu un
peu à l'avant garde en fait de ce qui se
fait actuellement et la préco vide comme
on dit les derniers seront les premiers
nous on n'est qu'à la troisième édition
mais ça se positionne aujourd'hui parmi
les battles les plus importants en
france et et voire même au niveau
continental et la france at elle une
chance de médaille attendre attendre de
voir quelle bboy qu'elle bigger seront à
sélectionner côté france mais les
spécialistes que l'on a pu interroger
l'as poissy ont été formels ils nous ont
affirmé que la nouvelle génération était
très prometteuse côté femmes par exemple
carlotta dudek est l'une des espérances
tricolore vous la voyez avec ce
survêtement rose à l'image et si l'on
s'en réfère à des résultats récents
michael les jeux olympiques de la
jeunesse en 2018 à buenos aires il y
avait la france qui avait de l'année une
médaille d'argent grâce à un certain
martin le jeune la jeunesse se
retrouvant en 2024 c'est tout ce qu'on
souhaite en tout cas grégory merci
beaucoup et on vous retrouve le mois
prochain pour votre chronique jo-2000 24
des candidats on passe maintenant à un
autre
coup de projecteur chaque semaine tv 70
vous propose un zoom sur un club sportif
ym ywha ou des sportifs heavy noah
aujourd'hui nous sommes allés du côté du
golf de saint germain en laye un golf
historique regardez
[Musique]
et
bienvenue au golf de saint jean morlet
l'un des plus anciens des yvelines
[Musique]
le club de saint germain en laye va
fêter à ses 100 ans une histoire riche
que je vous propose de regarder dans ce
reportage
il fêtera son 100e anniversaire dans un
an le golf le saint germain est implanté
dans la forêt depuis 1922 sur
d'anciennes terres agricoles le parcours
a été dessiné par l'un des meilleurs
architectes de l'époque harry colts le
britannique inconscient un parcours
forestier reconnu dans le monde entier
avec notamment 116 bon coeur à saint
germain est considérée suivant suivant
le entre employé le mot anglais au
ranking parmi les dix plus beaux
parcours de l'europe continentale pour
certains dans les cinq parcours d'europe
continentale mais c'est sûrement le
parcours le le plus célèbre le plus
ancien au développement le parcours
évinois organisé neuf open de france
dont le dernier en 1985 avec la victoire
de severiano ballesteros les greens ont
en plus accueilli la légende bénodet le
célèbre golfeur au 64 victoires sur le
tour américain des personnalités
prestigieuses sont également venus
assange à mansle et à partir de 1945
saint germain et l état major de l'armée
américaine et nous avons reçu ici
notamment
le général eisenhower le général m
d'isère mais surtout le général than à
voir nous avons aussi reçu ici le duc de
windsor qui venait régulièrement jouer
au golf de la propriété qu'il avait en
bordure du bois de boulogne aujourd'hui
le golf associatif reçoit régulièrement
des professionnels ils organisent des
tournois et notamment des championnats
de france la structure compte près de
mille adeptes le plus jeune à trois ans
et le plus ancien 96 ans au delà de la
compétition ce club familial prône avant
tout un style de vie est membre d'un
club comme saint germain c'est accepter
le cédait ses vêtements d'un club à la
britannique c'est à dire vivre comme
seul pour son club accepter les
différentes compétitions qui sont là et
retrouver des amis et de ne pas venir
uniquement taper des balles et repartir
après une partie pour rejoindre ce club
historique il faut être parrainé par
deux membres les admissions lieu deux
fois par
donc mon dieu
[Musique]
m
il est
[Musique]
on vient de le voir le club de saint
germain en laye a une histoire très
riche laurent vous confirmez oui on a
une soirée très riche effectivement une
histoire sportive bien sûr ce que c'est
plus ça qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
on est un club bientôt centenaire et on
a une politique ici très très sportive
alors à la fois vis des vies de nos
membres et vis-à-vis des des golfeurs
français puisqu'on reçoit très
régulièrement et on organise très
régulièrement des tournois
français et internationaux alors là
récemment vous avez organisé la gaule
firth c'était du 13 au 17 octobre tout
simplement est-ce que ça s'est bien
passé ça s'est très très bien passé on a
eu d'abord eu beaucoup de chance avec le
temps le parcours était fantastiquement
préparer et alors nous malheureusement
on a été battu en quart de finale par sa
non qui a remporté finalement le tournoi
mais c'était une très belle épreuve on a
eu du monde le dimanche et le samedi
pour suivre le lait les différentes
parties et je crois que c'est un tournoi
qui a fait l'unanimité au niveau des
joueurs et des spectateurs donc on est
très content est ce que l'objectif c'est
aussi de sortir des pépites de ce club
de saint germain en laye alors oui c'est
de sortir des pépites mais nous on a un
doute d'un double objectif le premier
objectif c'est de former des golfeurs
parce que tout le monde ne sera pas
champion tout le monde n'a ni l'envié ni
les possibilités donc nous c'est avant
tout former des des golfeurs qui vont
aimer ça qu'ils vont progresser qui vont
être des golfeurs toute leur vie et puis
parmi tous ces jeunes qu'on entraîne on
en a quelques uns qui vont être des
golfeurs de haut niveau ou des golf de
haut niveau mais ça ça concerne à chaque
fois
4 5e jeunes dans nos garçons quatre cinq
jeunes filles donc c'est pas l'essentiel
de ce qu'on fait mais bien sûr qu'on
essaie de former des jeunes de haut
niveau on les accompagne donc on les
forme avec hugo qui est vraie force de
notre école de golf et puis les autres
pros du du club on les entraîne on les
aide à aller participer à des tournois à
l'extérieur en france à l'international
et donc c'est la politique un peu global
qu'on connaissait d'avoir ici au niveau
du goal de saint germain on essaye de
créer un esprit saint jean les wii alors
ça c'est très importantes à dire que
nous on est très attaché à l'esprit
sportif mais on est aussi très attaché à
l'esprit familial du club c'est à dire
que nous nos équipes s'entendent bien
elles prennent plaisir à s'entraîner
ensemble elles prennent beaucoup de
plaisir à se déplacer ensemble en
tournoi et c'est quelque chose qui est
très important pour nous il ya à la fois
ce côté sportif mais ce côté convivial
qui est fondamental au niveau du club
hugo on le disait il ya des pépites qui
sont formés ici au club de saint germain
en laye il n'y a pas que des pépites non
effectivement on s'occupe aussi des tout
petits ont commencé avec eux justement
c'est dès le plus jeune âge on peut
les aider à se développer donc on sonne
à organiser notre école de golf pour que
le dimanche on est tous les jeunes à
partir de 6 ans qu'ils puissent du coup
créé déjà une cohésion une amitié créer
des affinités et s'entraîner du coup
pendant l'école de golf pour progresser
et ensuite des qui bascule autour du
collège la sixième la 5e on les fait
basculer le samedi donc là on retrouve
encore une fois deux catégories de
joueurs on a le loisir qui est toujours
là qui du coup vie son golf beaucoup
plus en détente voir les copains jouer
au golf à l'est sur le parcours et on a
évidemment aussi des groupes de haut
niveau qui représente du coup nos goûts
nos équipes u16 et qui après à l'avenir
on a l'espoir de les faire monter dans
l'aisne nos équipes une pour jouer tous
et la grenouille ou et du coup c'est
jouer ces joueurs là on les a comme les
autres joueurs 1h30 le samedi et on les
aide à progresser sur du contenu
beaucoup plus entraînement avec beaucoup
d'individualités en cohésion et on
travaille avec leur coach individuel
aussi parce que c'est des jeunes qui
s'entraînent va pas forcément avec moi
avec d'autres pros et du coup l'idée
c'est de faire coïncider le travail de
chaque pro avec son joueur on en haut
cour d'école de golf donc beaucoup
d'individualités pour les faire
progresser énormément
[Musique]
on va maintenant rencontrer ses pépites
ses joueurs prometteurs du club de saint
germain en laye eugénie adrien carla et
jules alors le génie pourquoi sans
jugement les mois je suis allé à saint
germain pour son équipe parce que c'est
une équipe qui est hyper familiale
tout le monde se tire vers le haut et je
suis également venu pour la qualité du
parcours et la qualité aussi du club
adrien c'est un peu les mêmes réponses à
peu près la même réponse je dirais que
saint germain est un super club parce
qu'ils croient vraiment en nous dès
qu'on fait des bons résultats on reçoit
des messages du directeur qui nous dit
babouins bien joué et continuent à
continuer là-dessus et on était super
coach les coaches sont incroyables à
saint germain on a des supers zone des
super structure d'entraînement donc
voilà c'est vraiment un super club car
là ce club de saint jean molla et est ce
que ça peut te faire progresser car là
ce club de saint jean d'angély ah bah
oui surtout que je suis pas arrivé il
n'y a pas très longtemps au final et
du coup les zones d'entraînement comme
des âneries elles sont vraiment génial
et les coachs ça change de ça change et
on progresse je laisse coach à ce
sentiment là aussi que tu peux franchir
un palier en étant ici au club de
saint-jean m'en vais bien sûr grâce aux
équipes aux dirigeants qu'ils apportent
une dynamique sportive récemment et
c'est sûr que les coaches sont super
forme et au niveau des nouvelles
technologies donc peut vraiment
progressé cet hiver et arrive à rêver
plus fort l'année prochaine toi quels
sont tes objectifs à l'avenir bas même
objectif long terme c'est de partir aux
etats-unis pour obtenir une bourse et
pourquoi pas passer pro même si même
s'il faut quand même un plan de secours
mais c'est sûr que en terme de deux
objectifs ce serait magnifique de
remporter les championnats de france par
équipes avec le club ce serait
fantastique et la coupe d'europe
forcément même si va falloir s'entraîner
pour sa carla toi aussi tu te diriges
vers une carrière aux etats-unis
peut-être une carrière professionnelle
ouais je sais ça l'objectif numéro 1
dans le fond et je pense que c'est pour
ça qu'on a un peu tous au début même si
c'est pour s'amuser c'est un peu pour ça
l'objectif final c'est de partir en fac
américaine pendant les 4 5 ans c'est
génial c'est une expérience même si au
final ça débouche pas sur une carrière
professionnelle ce que j'aimerais quand
même c'est quand même une expérience que
ce soit linguistique ou scolaires et
golfique évidemment mais c'est
extraordinaire
[Musique]
quelques semaines plus tard nous
rencontrons notre golfeuses du club
alexandra bonetti une joueuse qui a
percé au niveau professionnel
bonjour alexandra
oui ça vas y toi alors plein
entraînement
on est une petite mise en situation à
lyon d'un exercice que je fais
régulièrement le matin pour travailler
mon stroke le petit donc le mouvement de
petits où tu as ces deux premiers ti
pour travailler le fait que la phase de
club reviennent bien centrer et ça c'est
pour la ligne de départ que la bahn
sortent bien en ligne en fait sa valeur
centre non je te laisse essayer
d'ailleurs
ce sera toi
[Musique]
alors faut bien mettre la même balle
vraiment là bien là doigts pour que
l'auteur soit entre les deux types
[Musique]
semble un peu compliqué à
lesquin
[Musique]
c'est effectivement difficile d'arrêter
ce qu'on vivait
donc c'est mon métier pour une raison
quand même
mais voilà ça c'est le mal voilà pour
ancrer la technique le matin et ensuite
une fois combat sur parcours c'est
automatisé on n'a plus besoin de penser
à la technique mais plutôt seulement à
la vitesse à l'api lecture de pente et c
est comme une fois tu l'as fait cet
exercice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
alexandra on est à saint germain en laye
pourquoi tu as choisi saint germain en
laye alors c'était quand j'avais 17 ans
en fait j'étais mort john hughes of
national et là bas il n'y a pas du tout
l'esprit de club il y avait une super
école de golf mais pas d'équipé féminine
donc il y avait les quatre clubs
parisiens qui forcément commencer à
toquer à la porte et j'ai choisi saint
germain par le parcours exceptionnel
bien sûr mais j'avais des supers copines
et l'ambiance m'avait toujours plus un
côté sportif mais un côté familial aussi
donc je veux me suis vraiment senti
extrêmement bien ici et dans ce cadre où
on a l'impression d'être à hossegor
donc hyper agréable on va revenir sur
sur ton parcours fait notamment partie
aux états unis très jeunes également
pourquoi alors c'était le seul moyen de
combiner études à haut niveau et golf
également au niveau où là bas on avait
20 heures de golf et et 20 heures
d'études à peu près par semaine donc
très intenses ont représenté la fac sur
les tournois universitaire on parcourait
les quatre coins des états unis des
parcours d'une qualité incroyable
là où le pid jet tours joue des tournois
chaque semaine des herbes différentes
donc pour préparer la carrière
professionnelle c'était idéal mais
qu'est ce que ça t'a permis justement
peut-être de renforcer son mental ta
technique qu'est ce que ça t'a permis de
renforcer le point de vue mental est
très important là-bas parce que les
américains ont vraiment une philosophie
différente une approche différente où la
technique passe presque au second plan
et tant qu'on arrive à mettre la balle
dans le trou ils s'en foutent ils sont
ravis et est du coup avec vraiment ce
mindset de positive attitude qu'on n'a
pas vraiment en france ça c'est clair et
qui aide beaucoup à relativiser et à
s'élever en ayant les mêmes capacités
qu'une autre personne au fait du coup
ton meilleur souvenir en tant que pro
alors c'est avoir la carte du let donc
le ladies european tour la première
division européenne féminine après
seulement un an chez les pros où tout
allait bien c'était génial on était
plusieurs françaises halal obtenir en
même temps en plus donc on avait pu
célébrer tout en simple c'était génial
tu bosse beaucoup on l'a vu un jeu
précédemment
dans quel but tut un rêve tu as des
objectifs dans les prochaines semaines
et prochains mois les prochaines années
alors non comme tu le sais j'ai eu des
petits soucis physiques qui ont un peu
stoppé mon élan et donc là je suis
redescendu en deuxième division
européenne
l'objectif de cette fin d'année en
décembre s'est barré obtenir la carte
complète sur la première division donc
ça on aura la réponse le 20 décembre ça
peut être cadeaux de noël ou non et
ensuite donc une fois que je retrouve ce
statut sur le ladies european tour de
m'affirmer d'être parmi les meilleurs de
faire partie d'une solesmes cup et à
long terme d'évoluer sur le circuit
américain qui nous devancent encore un
petit peu au niveau du niveau de jeu les
parcours les gains et c'est la saint
jean léon on parle beaucoup de taux est
ce que tu as l'impression d'être un
petit peu à un modèle pour les jeunes
filles qui sont ici au club alors
j'essaye d'en tout cas de l'être le
mieux possible
j'étais allé avec l'équipe des moins de
16 ans il ya quelques années
sur un championnat de france pendant la
reconnaissance de parcours pour essayer
de leur inculquer les différentes choses
que je fais pendant une reconnaissance
et j'espère que ça pourra se renouveler
dans le futur mais je veux pas non plus
cherché à la lumière et et j'aime et je
vois je suis je vois les résultats de
certaines jeunes là qui sont super donc
merci beaucoup merci michael une
histoire riche des golfeurs
professionnels et des golfeurs en
devenir le club de saint germain en laye
n'a pas fini de surprendre et l'année
prochaine le club organisera les
championnats d'europe féminins ça sera
en juillet 2022
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]